what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
i'm so excited because we got jeff and
uh we're putting him on the spot so what
do you got jeff how can i help
man i got a lot of things coming in the
pipe uh
you know life and detours and things i
had to walk out of work so i could take
this while i'm on lunch i plan my whole
day around being here today
because uh
the detours is really what my life has
been about for the last few years and
having things happen that i've not
expected unexpected but to embrace them
and to travel with it i'm going to be
quitting my job in the next couple of
weeks here we go wow wow
yeah i'm putting the two weeks notice in
probably within the next five days
i know quitting your job is a big
freaking deal i'm sorry to jump in real
quick how can we support you
man i'm not like i have the plan in
place right now i mean there's gonna be
a lot more time for me to reach out and
actually get
networking again with all the people i
used to have but with life you know
taking over and having them i have no
place to live right now i'm living in my
rv but that's almost sold next week so
that's gonna be done and i have a new
job that's gonna take me all over the
country so it's gonna be but it's gonna
give me plenty of time to create videos
and share those moments and share all
the things i've done before
or seen before but this time i can
document it okay keep your eyes on the
road as you go man you're making me
nervous
oh i'm good now i'm good though
okay what do you got how can i help man
what do we got
okay so i've been watching a lot of the
uh
the traveling truck drivers and i'm
going to be getting my cdl again i did
drive from the time i was 21 to 27 and i
was older a truck driver um i have a
position available where i'm going to
be basically running
about five different dedicated routes
and it's a one big loop i'm going to
live in the truck for the next six
months to a year and just take all of my
vacations everywhere i'm at um
and it's gonna still be detours i'm
trying to find new unique locations but
this is just gonna put me nationwide
so wherever they send me it's gonna be a
new thing um
you know
i know i'm doing a little bit of a shift
again for the 15th time
but
i think that's what my audience is used
to and everything so selling it
shouldn't be that big of a deal um how
fast let's i'll ask this question how
fast should i concern myself with
anything but the content so like swag or
trying to work on a website or trying to
work on should i should i even dedicate
anything to that or should i just
basically get super consistent and study
on that for three to six months and then
go from there yeah i would i would i
would definitely focus on just getting
content up
um i don't even care if your audience is
used to it or not
because you're not going back to who you
were before
so
you know that's that's that's the prison
that a lot of people put themselves in
is like oh i have to keep doing what i
was doing because that's what people
expect of me it's like okay well
you know you're not that person you're
gonna hate your life more and more and
more
if you keep trying to be that person so
whether your audience you know whatever
your audience is now whether they like
it or not it doesn't matter because it's
who you are so the ones who would like
that will join you and the ones who
don't cool
but go follow somebody else we got we'll
send them to zane
and and you'll attract a whole bunch of
new people in as well
um
content for sure i wouldn't i wouldn't
stress out too much about swag anything
else especially if it's part of the
business model like if you want to wear
if you want
merch for yourself to wear and then that
might turn into something cool
but uh you know
the monetizing off of clothing isn't is
just that's not where a lot of money is
you know it's not that's not the game
you know blog
should it be something or still content
over everything for six months and then
take it from there
well blog would be if you actually enjoy
writing
i've done it so many times i've i do
enjoy it and i think there's a spot for
it that could fit out there but i don't
know i haven't done it consistently to
know if i'm gonna like it or not but
it's something i should even
i'm just trying to not overwhelm myself
over the next six months and i think the
most important is content i just kind of
want backing on that stay consistent on
the content
and then whatever else comes you can
explore and have some fun with but don't
make it this giant pressure on yourself
like we need jeff and his message and
the detours getting out there to the
world because even with the content it's
been like start and stop and start and
stop and here we go and then and then
where he's gone for you know and then he
starts again so it's great
now let's get consistent and and take
people on the journey so even even in
the process of you quitting your job
like it can start it can start now you
could start in your car right now like
guys i'm doing something new
i'm quitting my job
without my two weeks notice i'll get
fired that's the only reason
no no you can you can film it now
and then don't release it until two
weeks
well see now right there i didn't even
i'm i'm yeah i don't even know why i
didn't even think of that it's just
holding that moment here's what you need
to do like if you honestly if you just
created a schedule where at the
beginning at least every week a video
every week a video every week a video
right and then hopefully we're having
like multiple videos coming up every
week but if you force yourself to say
okay i have to make a video this week
then you'll you would come up with that
idea
and you come up with much better ideas
you come up with all sorts of insane
ideas because that's how your brain is
genius when you direct it
right
okay if i am scatterbrained i go every
direction all at once and that's always
been my problem since the day i met you
was focus
you're giving yourself the out
like that's the thing you got to stop
giving yourself the out like a video has
to be recorded oh but i'm not quitting
my job for two weeks or whatever i
haven't put in my notice so that's the
out so it's okay now now you don't have
to produce right there's always going to
be some out
that you'll convince yourself and not
just you this is this applies to lots of
creators that we convince ourselves that
we're not going to do i don't feel
creative today i'm tired i didn't sleep
well last night like oh i ran out of gas
in the truck it was really rough day
like there's always
if we wait for the perfect time it's
never the time and we always give
ourselves the out so like stop giving
yourself the out and then your brain
will we're using it in a creative way to
help you make what you need to make
it's like every week a video has to be
recorded
and then inside of that you'll you'll
find you'll make some amazing things
never put up a zero says andrew there
you go i i saw that no more zeros and
the funny thing is even at the car
dealership that's on our board it says
never never a day with a zero so
and listen even if the video doesn't
always fit into the format right like
that's where give yourself the
permission to detour maybe you're going
and and
today's video you're trying out a new
restaurant that you've never tried
before you've never done a restaurant
review or you're you're rescuing some
raccoon on the side of the road and like
what i don't know what it is like this
is where you
you you can have fun with it and be
creative like within the constraint of i
have to make a video
this week
but then what kind of video
you might have a format that you like
and you stick to but then every now and
then it's it's being willing to shift
from it because if you only did the same
kind of video every time too you're
gonna start going crazy just knowing you
like you're going to have to shake it up
and do it i know the privilege of is i
know what seven years on the road did
for me a long time back and i know the
freedom i had and the time i had because
i had so much extra time i did so many
things and now knowing what i know about
documenting
it's i get to show the world what i
loved about trucking for seven years and
what and it's not even really trucking
what i loved about travel and and being
out there and meeting new people and
just experiencing life and that's
you don't always know where life's going
to take you but you know you never know
where life's going to take you uh no but
that's it and like imagine if you had
just started if you would start if you
had filmed those seven years and
sticking to that doing that like you'd
be in a totally different spot right now
and and then the point of that is not to
make you feel bad and say hey you suck
jeff it's to use that as fuel going
forward to say okay like if i film the
next three years of my life doing i'm
gonna be in a totally different spot
it's gonna be wild and different like
maybe you're doing coaching calls and
talking and doing interviews like you
have your podcast and you're you're
interviewing elon musk from your truck
as you're driving to texas or whatever
like who knows like you're gonna you're
gonna come with some wild stuff that's
just gonna happen
but
he asked me point blank about six weeks
ago
uh
the one thing you kind of not regret but
if you could make better and i was like
i wish i could have documented the seven
years on the road and he's like that was
your answer to if you if you should go
take this new job with your sister or if
not and and that was kind of my
yep that's okay all this time i've been
waiting for this moment and june 30th
was my date i'm a little delayed on it
but that's okay but
i'm like yeah that's it i have the
position available to me if i want it
and
you know now it's that was my biggest
regret life is to be able to see all
this stuff but never be able to share it
so you're documenting the detours but
but how you document and what you
document can change a million times
exactly
i appreciate you so much evan time to
get to work and today needs a video jeff
we need a video today
i'm going to turn this thing sideways
there it is all right
i can start filming right after this
or leave this and go make your video who
cares about this well i'm going to i'm
going to listen i'm going to listen and
eat lunch so i'm going to listen to you
okay good get inspired but video has to
happen today
yes sir all right we love you jeff
tanya's got her hand up tanya hello
everyone
uh so i have uh a question let's see if
i can
can explain myself so i'm working on
my youtube channel and uh
what i want to do with this youtube
channel the the message i want to to
work on is um make people believe that a
radical change in life is possible
and inspire them to initiate their
journey with an immigrant mindset
that means not turning back enjoy the
journey
and give everything you have upon
arrival to live your dream
so
that's that's like my my main my main
motivation let's say
and uh
i thought about i doing this list of
people that i want to interview and you
know to start getting
get it rolling
but there are many people and many
interesting stories that they are not
necessarily uh immigrants it's more like
an internal journey because sometimes
the journey is like that sometimes it
takes you to somewhere else
geographically but sometimes it's
internal but when i was recording my
video
then i i was you know i i realized that
i was not
being able to to choose exactly how to
focus it
to make it clear what's the channel
about
does it make sense yeah okay so listen
let's um let's let's dance a little bit
with this so this is gonna be fun
first off i love it like you're telling
people to believe in themselves to live
their i mean this is great
yes i love this podcast already use the
magic word okay so you have a couple
options and
and the option that fits best is the one
that's in your heart that's gonna fit
the best right so i'll just pepper them
and you tell me which one resonates
it all really will come down to what you
believe
an immigrant to be so it could be
immigrant physically like what most
people would think immigrant being like
hey
you're in canada born somewhere else
you're coming here exposing a new
country cool
um that's a that's kind of that feels
like the limitation you're being stuck
on right now like well what if they
weren't an immigrant to the country but
they still have have
overcome obstacles and objections uh so
you could stick to that
view traditional view what an immigrant
looks like
the next path out is immigrant mindset
so
what does immigrant mindset mean well if
it's like
hard work and hustle and no excuses and
like whatever you think
make up the immigrant mindset
that could apply to a lot more people
even though they may not be an immigrant
by the textbook definition but they have
the immigrant mindset that you recognize
and you want to bring people on for
that's still like
that's a little bit of a leap it's not a
big leap but it's it's a little bit of
leap from where you were
the the bigger leap out is then
recognizing that
everybody's an
immigrant like if you're trying to build
a new life
separate from what your family is right
like this is what i grew up and what my
parents taught me and i want to build a
different life and i wind up in a
different spot
i'm an immigrant in those situations
in jeff taking on this new challenge in
his life is like unless his dad was a
trucker and documented his journey he's
saying no
then jeff is
him having the courage to quit his job
and go trucking and document it is is
living in an immigrant life
because he's trying to build something
brand new that's never been done before
for him and what he's used to
so they're like leaving a country and
going to another country is basically
what jeff is doing even though he's in
the us and he's not like an immigrant by
textbook definition so
it all depends on how you want to define
immigrant
and how much you want to stretch it
from a textbook only i'm only going to
bring people who are like physically
immigrated to the ken to the country to
immigrant mindset and whatever that
means to you to then recognizing that
everybody's actually if you're on a
growth path everybody in the world is an
immigrant how much do you want to
stretch it what feels right
like where is the answer for you
i would say that um the
everybody is an immigrant it's very
appealing
like
we all have this journal journeys right
every whoever makes a journey immigrates
from one state to other so that's
definitely very appealing
now i think that
a central point of
what i would like to stress is the
immigrant mindset
and uh that also kind of like focus on a
specific specific type of of of
people that you know would be interested
in doing this
so it's a yeah it's
in my mind yes i would like to include
people not necessarily immigrant by the
textbook i don't want to limit myself to
that because i i just know so many
amazing people who have not immigrated
geographically but have made these
journeys
so i would like to stay
there like not not like because
part of the content that i want to put
out is
people you know sharing their decision
how they got to the decision what was
the initial state their journey how the
journey was you know for them the
arrival and also to share
to share kind of like tips and tricks
kind of clues on how they became
successful
in in doing this
so
yeah so that yes that's just on you then
to pull that out and make it make sense
for the audience so let me use zayn as
an example and i'm going to share two
zan examples because we just love zayn
uh
zayn had a very successful career in the
music industry
right
like djing huge events you you he's got
pictures with some of the world's most
famous people that he doesn't share and
show off because he's a humble guy and
we love him but but he was like top of
his game in the dj world
and
he decided to go into coaching
and when he did that people like what
are you doing dude what you've like had
it made here you're hosting the biggest
part is you're in vegas you're going to
coaching like this is not a smart move
right
so zen then had zen became an immigrant
in the coaching world
he had to leave his home his country
where he had had so much comfort and
community and connection and then moved
to a new country called coaching
and then he started getting
certification he started joining
programs and he started connecting with
people so that that the new country
became his his new country that he felt
welcome and accepted and became a leader
in his new countries he he took the
immigrant path to make that happen
instead of staying in in just a comfort
right um and
so zane can talk to that mindset and i'm
i'm summarizing this story he can go in
a lot deeper if you want to interview
him for your show but
that's a great example of the immigrant
mentality even though zan
was born and raised in the u.s and never
left
i guess he left the cold country and
went to vegas and now doesn't have to
worry about winter coats and snow and
anything anymore
but it's that immigrant mindset
um
one of my favorite conversation with zan
was talking about how
everything is coaching
it's like what is coaching zayn he's
like oh like you're having a session
you're coaching somebody and you you
tell them what to do and then they go
off and do it like okay well like if the
goal
is to get somebody to take action right
you the goal is for them to
come into your space and then they go
home and they do something to change
their life
you can accomplish that like that's
coaching cool but you can accomplish
that in so many more ways than just a
speech or just a one-on-one session like
when somebody and i know this goes up
you know from the salsa dancing world
when somebody comes into an event that
we would host where there's a great dj
in playing music have they ever left
that event
feeling happier
and then going off and deciding to make
some life change
yeah does it happen for everybody maybe
not but some people walk in to a club
listen to a dj
have a great time and then go home and
decide to quit their job or marry that
person or start a youtube channel or go
trucking or whatever right it's like you
made that happen
you made that you were playing even
though you never met them they may not
have come up to you and told you what
happened as a result the vibe that you
brought the energy that you brought like
zan brings so much care and love and
energy into the thing everything that
he's doing so when he's pouring that
into music you made that vibe happen you
set up the scenario for them to go home
and then take that big life choice you
made that happen it was you that's
coaching
it's just expanding the definition of
what is coaching me
and so the same thing with uh you know
what is an immigrant
a lot of people can relate to the you
know the struggles of starting something
new and leaving the comfort of of home
behind to then go off and do it and so
you know that that's where i default to
living so like if that's where you want
to to play
it really broadens the spectrum of the
kinds of people that you can bring on
you just have to be intentional with how
you bring that story out
to say hey you know you you were an
immigrant moving from
you didn't move to new country but you
moved from the entertainment industry
into coaching zayn anything you want to
add to that i shared a lot and
summarized but you know it's your story
no everything you say is amazing it's
just i i mean what a talent to be able
to take something
and and and make it fit and make it so
relevant i just i'm sitting here just
like this guy is so talented
he can sum it up and make it relevant i
mean just that's a talent man i'm still
learning i'm still evan and i and one
part i will add is that evan has
deepened and widened my understanding of
what a coach is when a coach does
and uh it's because of him that i have a
such a deep understanding
of of
who i am as a coach and
and how i could be a blessing and a
service and value to other people but
yeah evan what a talent man
i mean i remember zen used to host my
gaming stream with me so we got into a
lot of discussions key to discussions
sometimes around these things but i mean
in the early zayn was like i can't coach
women i just can't coach women you know
now some of us the best people coaches
are women he said well there's coaching
in this therapy but i'm never going to
do therapy like that's not what i do and
then he goes to get certified in
cognitive behavior therapy right and but
like
it's not um
if anything is a credit to zane it's
like he's willing to go and expand the
definition and explore and so when i
said at the beginning of this time he
was like well let's see how much you
want to let's play
and let's let's have a dance let's see
how far you want to go with this because
you could stick to the textbook
definition and we can just stay there or
we can expand the definition which will
give you a lot more
creativity and more fun and amazing
things can happen and you're already
feeling the restriction like i want to
have these people line but it doesn't
fit the mold of what an immigrant is and
the more you can play and expand that
the more value you can bring people yeah
definitely thank you thank you so much
yeah that i guess is indeed your biggest
gift open people's minds
so i am really
really um starting to think like yes uh
there there is no need to restrict
um in the sense of you know people
actually
if there's so much uh room
to
you know to bring more interesting
people if i don't restrict the concept
of of the channel like leave it open and
just play around uh what it's to
immigrate from one state of mind or you
know physically to other and all the the
adventure that it includes
this is this is classic like heart heart
versus head decision making like your
heart wants to bring these people on
your show but your head doesn't
understand how to do it
and whenever they're battling like that
it's like the heart is always right like
these people need to be on your show
you just haven't figured out the how and
the structure around it yet because it
doesn't make sense but but they have to
like you don't want to not have they
have to be on your show or you're going
to regret it
right yes same thing with jeff going on
his detours and trucking and quitting
like he has to do it he has to do it if
he doesn't do it he's going to regret it
again in the next seven years but the
how of like who it's going to change
what is it a document is going to change
it's going to be all over the place
and if you judge yourself like oh i
didn't make it exactly the same as last
time
then you're staying small as opposed to
doing the thing that's like out of this
amazing things will be born
yeah i think so
so whenever like i mean thank you and
what i love about utan is you you
you show up and you ask questions and
you like admit what you're what you're
working through it's great like i would
have been too afraid
at the start of my journey it was my
biggest thing is i never asked for help
i didn't even know how to ask for help i
felt i should know the answers um so you
know
kudos to you because i probably wouldn't
have been here at the year at the start
of my journey so um i love how you ask
for help
and and are open to the feedback and
then you go do something with it it's um
really inspiring but whenever whenever
it's like i want to do something that
feels so right but it doesn't make sense
whenever they're fighting head in the
heart the heart's always right
and so you have to tell the brain okay
well we're gonna make this make sense
somehow so let's get on board and make
it happen
right like if we had jeff had to make a
video every week
he'll find a way to make it happen
he'll just he'll be creative and make it
if you had to make that happen you have
to bring these people on the show you'll
find a way to make it happen and you did
by even coming here and posing a
question
yeah the brain will find a solution to
follow the heart so like heart first
when your heart's telling you do
something you have to go you have to
have to have to have to do it and then
your brain will help you figure out the
how
yeah and it was so hard like it's it's i
feel it's so hard like it you know it's
just that i i i had to ask because i had
this you know inside and i had to ask
so so to give it yeah like to be able to
because i i recorded so many videos and
it was not feeling right how to do it so
you know i have to ask even though it's
you know
saying something that still not yet
there and it's kind of like pressure but
i didn't wanted to keep it to myself so
thank you so much for i love and listen
for everybody too like bring it up bring
it up sooner when it's in your heart you
feel it but you can't often bring words
to it and it doesn't make sense and like
you haven't you haven't crystallized the
thought properly yet because your head
doesn't understand it so if your head
doesn't understand you can't communicate
it very well but you just use the best
words that you can to to get it out
there and in magical things will start
to happen um anyway huge credit to you
we love you tanya thank you for sharing
thank you for showing up the movie
makers and being here let's see ej's got
her hand up what do we got hey there
thanks for being here today i had
i get really excited about doing content
and then just as i'm ready to do it i'm
like oh everything follows it in my head
i get really scared i just and then
nothing comes out or i'll make content
and then i won't post it and so some
suggestions on how to kind of
overcome
that yeah so a couple things that helped
me one i still posted it so like expect
to suck and post and and it gets a
little bit better
every time and that that becomes the the
journey and the lesson for other people
watching as well that they see you and
you can even say
i had all this stuff planned and i
totally forgot what i was gonna say
and here and then post that you know
like post
get used to posting the imperfections
because that's actually what's really
inspiring um
when i when i broke my neck in 2019 and
still film videos all through that and i
can cut like those were not my best
videos but people found it really
inspiring that i would even i wasn't
even thinking that way it's like i still
got to make videos
but people are more inspired by those
videos and than the ones before because
it's just a willingness to show up with
everything that happened i was a worse
version of me than i was before but they
were inspired by the action so lean into
it like it's the it's the difference
between what you think you're capable of
and what you're capable of in the moment
and so leaning into that to say hey i'm
i forgot everything like if i forgot
that's part of the video
i had this perfect video lined up and
now i'm i forgot everything but here's
what i want and then you go and then you
post and then tomorrow's another video
and the next week's
whatever your cadence is but the next
one's it's happening and it's happening
just to teach yourself that it's okay to
make mistakes and it's okay to not be
perfect and it's okay that if the
microphone breaks halfway through where
the light goes off or you have a leak in
the roof or like whatever i don't know
whatever happens or you just brain fart
and forget you just
just keep going because it's actually a
better skill to learn than to have
everything be perfect um the other thing
that helps me is is just tying it like
that's the most important thing because
if you're concerned about perfection
you'll never create anything
but tying it in a service
when i get it out of my head
and into other people that your message
today matters like the video that you're
recording today is not just about you
it's not about your ego it's not about
the follower account it's like you have
something in your heart that you want to
share with people that can help them
like your message can help somebody
maybe it doesn't reach a million people
but it can it can help somebody
and by you not posting a video you're
cheating the person from the opportunity
to
maybe make a life-changing decision
and whenever it's only about me i play
small
but whenever i can make it about even if
it's a even if it's like made up
right like i used to imagine an
entrepreneur friend of mine he was the
camera so i'm not talking to the camera
i'd imagine him and i'm talking to him
and i'm so it was made up but it felt
like i was doing something that was
meaningful to him at least
and so i i posted and it gave me more
strength and more courage to still show
up in perfect imperfectly like it's it
still won't be perfect you'll never it
took me 750 videos 700 videos sorry
until i was inspired by myself right
where i watched it back like oh
getting good let's go right 700 videos
so i sucked a lot and and we are our own
worst critic always everybody can relate
to that who's here you know on the call
um so yeah just the permission to be
imperfect and the permission to to suck
and the permission for it not to go well
and permission to it's okay that you
lost your train of thought in the middle
of it because you're nervous
and just say that
and then and then tie it to service so
like hopefully it still helps somebody
and if you could feel that it's helping
somebody it's not about you anymore
it'll give you more courage to show up
i connect like
i resonate so deeply with it because i
struggled so much with it
and i think everybody can connect with
that on some level too
if you do it like i can see doing that
once but like you did 700 you can't stay
in 700 videos well
you know like
but don't worry about 700 because you'll
get better
you know right like anything else how
long did it take you to ride a bike or
how long take you to like whatever skill
set you have how long did it take the
first two times versus
you start to get like it's surprising
how quickly you get better at the thing
like how to do instagram live oh my gosh
and then like oh it wasn't you know why
that's not that bad i could do that
so it's a great it's a great um it's a
great tool that you can use
and maybe in the beginning you're using
it more than others
but
you won't you won't fall back on that
tool for 700 videos
right you'll just get better at it it'll
be okay
so don't worry about having a tool that
you have to use every single time
right
okay but even if you did like even if
you use it for the this is how i think
of it now right if you used it
say took you like 50 videos of doing
that every time for 50 like that's a
you'll get there faster but let's say
like you were just the worst and it took
you 50 videos
right like just imagine it took you 50
every 50 videos you struggled and
stammered and lost your train of thought
and just completely blanked out during
the headlights and you used that same
technique for fifth imagine that and
then at 51 you got it and you stopped
using it and 50 and then you're on a
path now imagine when your video 200 in
how much better you are and you can go
back and show people guys look at my i
suck so bad look at my first 50 videos i
couldn't even get a word out of my face
for 50 videos
right it becomes like your struggle that
is so painful and overwhelming actually
becomes the inspiration because people
can see a new
humanity
and vulnerability and authenticity and
the willing like courage
to keep posting and keep going even
though it completely sucked at the start
so if you have that and you can kind of
project to being on the other side of it
how much of an inspiration are you going
to be for people
to say hey you know what if she can do
it
maybe i can too
and it will probably won't take me 50
videos to get there
that's why i show like the early days of
my youtube stats right
on my website right the first five years
like if i just shared the first five
years in isolation like this guy sucks
but the fact that then it gets to three
and a half million or whatever it's like
in the looking backs how did you keep
going when it was so bad right
it's the same thing what was in my
calendar i had to do it and i focused on
service and and i released imperfect
things so yeah just a little perspective
shift to say hey you've got
decades ahead of you of doing this kind
of stuff people just show back your
first it won't take you 50. but even
your first three or five or ten or
whatever it's like look at i couldn't
even even if you just press record and
it's you staring into the camera
post
next
what an inspiration to look back and see
right yeah okay cool i did i did a
series of them like a few and then i
just kind of
got in my own head and then i stopped
yeah well that
like we all get in our own head and
stopped like look at the theme of today
jeff got in his own head and stopped
tanya wants to have these people on her
show and got on her own head and like
hasn't done it right it's like this is a
human thing i get in my own head
and stop
talking about zayn and
what is coaching got in his own head and
stopped right we all get in our own
heads and stop which is the value of a
community like this and coaches to help
kind of push you through it and say hey
you know what like here's a perspective
shift that you might want to think about
that can help get you to where you need
to go
awesome thank you
every week we look at a new topic and uh
and then and then we brainstorm and chat
and like whatever you whatever you need
help on so
this week's topic was maria who picked
niche picking one and staying with it
how to narrow when in it to include
another niche
uh well since we have maria here why
don't we workshop this a little bit what
what's uh what's on your mind rio
where's this coming from
thank you evan and thank you so much for
i'm just blown away with your generosity
with the challenge and
anyway um thank you so i've been you
know i've
shifted my niche a few times over the
years because i address women that
struggle in their relationship to food
weight and body image but it's typically
the tip of the iceberg and usually the
deeper blocks being emotional blocks
sometimes trauma sometimes stress
management sometimes that's where you
have to go to have
long-term healing and so
i'm you know i i market to that
particular population but i work with
people that struggle with anxiety
because that's usually the next layer
right people are medicating with food
it's a lot of times they're medicating
their anxiety or their and one of the
things i just watched your interview
with melanie because i i am a
emotional freedom techniques master
practitioner and that's one of the
techniques that i actually use
one of them that help people to have
more peace in their with their emotional
body so my question is
do i just stick to this niche or do i
broaden it like when is like when is the
time to do that or do i just keep doing
what i'm doing and because for instance
i'll work with someone and then she'll
send me her husband because her husband
has
anxiety issues you know
so
i don't know if that's clear no no i
mean they get great and think everybody
kind of struggles with forms of this at
some point when they're figuring out
their content their audience um what you
need to think about is who
so in in looking at your titles for the
movement makers challenge that we're
going through right now all your titles
came back to helping women right like
everything said women which is fine so
you know i love i'll believe in anybody
i like if somebody if you sent me
somebody who or i'm talking to somebody
who's an employee and never wants to be
an entrepreneur i'll still have the
conversation help them it's just not
really what i want to be doing you know
it's like it's not at the core of what i
love the most because that's
i love serving entrepreneurs more so it
doesn't mean that hey because you're a
man i'm not gonna talk to you
you know but if you love serving women
then you focus on that audience first
inside of that
you get the pick is it really mental
health stuff that you love about
i love caring about is it really the
weight loss journey because that leads
to the mental health stuff you know like
who do you love
helping the most like if you had to pick
we all love serving we all love helping
if we see somebody fall on the street
we're going to go and
and help them up
i hope
readers built to serve readers okay you
see somebody follow the street you go
help them up
but that's not like what we want to you
know be spending our days doing it's
just we see somebody in need and we do
what we can to support
um
you know right now uh
the whole thing in ukraine like my main
video editor
her she's ukrainian and she left
three no she left like five years ago
from ukraine to go to montenegro
and um
because of war and potential war and all
that so she's safe but her family is
in the ukraine and we've been spending
the past time kind of figuring out hey
how how can i help i mean i'm
in canada like do they need money like
is your family safe can they fly out of
the country can they get somewhere where
they need to go you know i i don't speak
the language or have any connections but
uh if if money is a problem to get
people what they need like let me know
um
and
you know i'm helping with that but it's
not what i want my mission isn't going
into war-torn countries and helping
people escape but you know right so we
do what we can to serve the people who
are around us but like who do you who
would you spend or love spending the
most time with that's like just
absolutely feeds your soul
who are they and what are they
struggling with
in the challenge of the movement makers
thing we're going through right now is
to try to get it more specific so that
when you're making the content it's not
just
how to
fix your anxiety
which is great but specific to like who
are the people who you love helping the
most so
in that context who do you who would you
love helping like the most the most the
most
yeah so
my word is care
and my mission really is
i feel passionate about this is to to
help women to get beyond the struggles
that undermine them so that they can
stand in their life and and be their
best self and and serve in the way that
they've been called to serve because i
feel like the advancement of women
and you know we in this country we have
we have more freedom than many women on
the planet and yet we're emotionally
oppressed by body image issues and
weight issues and and all that chips
away
at us being our best self so i feel
passionate about that and also my story
is about that i've come from multiple
eating disorders and i've worked and
so i you know i'm on the other side of
that now and i feel like my purpose is
my passion i mean my pain has been my
passion
so yes that's that gives me greatest
pleasure when i have clients that are
you know getting beyond the dieting
stuff and and really looking you know
living a freer life and they're and
they're finding their purpose beyond
that and not teaching their little
daughters to be over
concerned about diet and weight but that
these girls can come into the world with
more empowered about
who they are as a person not necessarily
how they look
so i mean that's part of it yeah i mean
i love i love that you
so you have your niche women which is
awesome now now that's like
half of the population so we've narrowed
it down a little bit but
getting a little more specific to then
the next step and the problem that
they're facing
is helpful because if you only said
women
who
who aren't living their best lives
that's everybody that's every woman
that's every man too by the way you know
[Laughter]
stepping into a potential whatever so
it's very it's very broad which which is
the long-term mission but then inside of
that
who do you love
helping the most and whether it relates
to food or not
that's the discussion to start to figure
out it's like hey we can we can start to
build this niche and then expand from
there but inside of that like who do you
love
love love helping the most like do you
love helping
teenage girls get over a crush that
broke their heart on prom night
do you love helping
you know a woman who might have lost her
mom yesterday to cancer you know like
there's so many issues that we will face
and so it's great to target women
but then what are they struggling with
the most that you love helping them
through and then that becomes
most of the content that you start with
so you can start building your tribe
around it yeah yeah yeah yeah
so something like come to mind or is it
just more like thinking well it is women
that are caught in in struggling
with weight thinking they need a diet
that's going to fix them because it's
really an inside job right and so i get
great set like for instance i've been
working with a new client recently and
after a couple of weeks she's come to
the realization that it's really not
about her weight her unhappiness and her
and that's gives me great gratification
and satisfaction yes she wants to still
be healthy and treat her body with
respect
but
giving up the struggle and learning to
trust herself more
is
that that's what gives me great
gratification that she's she's really
feeling more
of um
taking caring enough about herself
that she is willing to have healthier
boundaries with her husband and rather
than focusing on the body image and all
of that getting beyond that is that is
that clear yeah yeah i think that's
great like
behind every for all everybody here you
want to have an impact and we all have a
message to
to serve other people
these strategies alone are not going to
be enough
like just telling somebody here's what
you do here's the foods to eat if i
could just tell somebody hey make these
videos go that's not enough because
there's there's emotional resistances
to everything
so you could tell somebody to eat this
food but there's a reason why they're
abusing the food in the first place all
of us have blocks that prevent us from
doing the next thing and so
understanding that
really helps so
women you're helping
they're they're stressed out or they
have anxiety they have body
issues and
some of them the ones who you'll like
helping the most
they solve they they feed their
anxiety and stress with food
others might do it through drugs others
might do nothing or relationships or or
they cut themselves or they you know
like and
so that's where like well do you want to
help those women too if somebody's
saying like i've tried to kill myself
four times
because i hate my body like maybe maybe
you don't turn that person away you know
but it's not like the core of what you
want to deal with because it's not the
same path
that you went through right so if women
great awesome plus anxiety stress
self-confidence issues great that's
going to be everybody but how do they
fix though how are they getting their
fix off
is through food
yeah and so you're still addressing the
underlying thing but also helping them
solve the connection to getting their
fix with food right so it's like food
but you're not just going to teach diet
plans
no
you're going to teach them techniques
underneath
really
of course and but it's not just that
those techniques only work through food
it could also apply to people who are
cutting themselves or oh yes
or for men too who are doing these it's
just not as much
of a connection to you because you
haven't gone through
those things yeah well i've gone through
other addictive behaviors and
and and on because really my
understanding you know if you if you
just transfer one addiction to another
the expression is you're changing seats
on the titanic i mean you're not
addressing the underlying you're still
going down right
and what years ago when i worked in an
eating disorder unit by the time people
got there they had gone through drug
addiction and and gambling addiction and
so all of that stuff is relevant
and yes
though as i work with people for
instance i'll work with somebody who's a
food issue and then all of a sudden
after a couple weeks they feel safe
enough with me to real to to reveal that
they drink a bottle of wine every night
and so
as we uncover
the core reasons so it's you know on the
on unsaid i i mature i tracked people
and sometimes people don't know oh
well i guess it has more to do with
rapport and intimacy and trust as they
get to know me and they feel safe with
me then they reveal more
about who they are and also knowing if
you've been through the thing that
they're going through because you can
make the connection between addictive
behaviors but other people may not right
so like have you ever lost your home
because of a gambling problem
well my father was a compulsive gambling
gambler and we lost many homes
but so that's that speaks to like family
so my family members doing this but have
you ever done it
have i lost a home i haven't lost a home
but i've
lost a lot i don't have a gambling issue
great so but i have an issue with
supporting men
because that came out of that dynamic
that my mother
i've had in my history i don't do that
today but in my history i've supported
men and given them a lot of money
great i'm a little ashamed of even
saying that but it was because of the
dynamics of the gambling
you know so that was well listen you're
in a safe space and thank you for having
the courage to share that with us if you
haven't told other people before but
these are things that you can speak to
right it's not that if somebody has
their own gambling problem
um
you won't help them but it's just not
it's not you you you didn't go and lose
your home but if somebody came and said
my father has
again or my mother or somebody my family
has a gambling addiction or i keep
supporting people for some reason why do
i keep supporting these men who have
gambling problems what is wrong with me
like somebody that person you would love
helping
so much more than
i have a gambling problem because it's
more through your experience of what
you've lived like if somebody came to
you and said i keep supporting men who
have gained problems what's wrong with
me
and then you help them realize there's
nothing wrong with you
right and you teach them to actually
love yourself and just get out of these
negative relationships that's going to
make you feel amazing yes
so it's and hopefully we're spending a
lot of time on this but hopefully
everybody can see that kind of similar
journey for your own self the thing that
you have been through where you felt
hopeless worthless like
when your dad did that and you lost your
home where you gave money and
just how terri like it made you feel
terrible about yourself
and if you then subsidize through foods
like okay well i'm just gonna go eat
that pizza or doritos or whatever just
to make me feel good because i don't
have any happiness in my life anywhere
right like
this is where people get really stuck so
that's your niche you know the people
who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled through and it doesn't
mean we ignore everybody else we can't
help them and we're going to turn them
away but it's not who we're actively
trying to go out and serve because if
you just go out and say ladies have more
self-confidence
it becomes too broad a message
but then you end up we are trying to
serve everybody and ends up serving very
few people yeah
does that help yes it's very helpful i
have one more so the other thing is
though one of the modalities that i do
use is tapping and i really love the
conversation you had with melanie
because it's not all the only thing i
use and but a lot of my youtube videos
have been focused on that because
there's a whole niche of people
that are but i use the tapping specific
to that
weight body image and
so like who i how right
from built to serve that's the how the
how
the how
matters less about what the how is and
matters more that you believe in the how
like if if somebody sees you and say i'm
in the same situation as maria i've been
over eating to combat my stress because
of whatever happened in my life
and you're gonna say i'm exactly like
you here's how i
got through it
tapping great show me how to do it like
the how does it matter
what matters is that it actually worked
for you
yeah and that because i love you and i
connect to your story i'm gonna now have
more belief
in the strategy that you're gonna give
me on how to get out as well so if
tapping helped you then incorporate it
into your content
yes if it helped you for everything
great put it everywhere if it helped you
only for specific problems just
make it for those specific problems but
bringing it into your content bring it
into your coaching whatever got you out
of the hole
is the thing then you teach other people
because that's your job is to get them
out of the hole that they're in as well
and we all have we all have different
house right and you don't have to use
the same house for every situation but
how did you get out of the situation you
were in
and now we teach that
yeah we're thought leaders
i love it
it just reminds me somebody booked a
consult with me
tomorrow and
when i when somebody books i ask them to
just put anything that they have to say
and she said she said i'm not sure about
tapping but i'm sure about you she's
been following me for a while yeah and
um it really just spoke to what you were
saying she felt comfortable enough to
have the consult with me to potentially
work with me
but she wasn't sure about tapping yeah
like the how does it matter this is why
in movement makers for this challenge
that we're doing when when i'm rejecting
everybody putting in their like their
four steps to do things or the three
ways or the eight like the strategies do
not matter
what matters is a connection to you i
don't giving me eight strategies is not
the benefit
what's the specific the specific benefit
that i'm gonna get from working with you
and so that's the whole game if you get
them to to know you like you trust you
which comes from you telling your story
if i start talking about women's weight
issues
what's the you're not a woman you don't
know me you don't know what i'm going
through right like it's going to be the
first like who even if i have all the
same strategies
they're not going to listen to me
because i'm not a woman
right and
and that's an obvious like hopefully you
can tell that i'm not a woman
like that's a pretty obvious thing but
the thing is a lot of these things that
we
have struggled with are not obvious like
knowing that you struggled if i look at
you i don't think you struggle with food
if i look at you i don't think you had
men in your life who had gambling issues
that you supported so when you come out
and say here's how you solve it
it doesn't come across like who is this
woman who's preaching to me
right you're not
and this is hopefully the flick with
everybody like you're not coming down
from your high horse and preaching
people and telling people what to do
you're saying i'm just like you i was i
was in the same spot
and i struggled with this and here's how
i overcame but until you share that
story and i know that you've been
through it and you're you're like me
then then i'm not going to listen to you
so anyway
most things are not obvious right men
women obvious
you know ethnic background whatever scar
on your face like super obvious but most
of the things we deal with is not
obvious and so we need to share those
things and have the courage and you
honestly did it right here it's like i'm
a little embarrassed to say this
it's great
and sharing that will only connect more
people to you like nobody
if any people only feel more love for
you
in saying that you struggled with
supporting men who had gambling
addictions not oh
i'm not going to talk to maria now
because of that so thank you for having
the courage to uh to share up
thank you evan thank you for all that
you do
thank you
celine was asking what's the best way to
get one-on-one clients
so honestly the best way is through
referrals as much as i'm like a content
guy and i love making videos and content
but the best way is through referrals
like do a kick-ass job with the people
who you are doing work with so that one
they want to hire you back depending on
what you're selling and two they
introduce you to other people
but like this person is so good that
they want to tell their friends about
you and and being
most people won't give or give a bad
service like if somebody asked you if
you asked them how good was my service
they'll probably say oh yeah yeah you
did great but is it so good that they
want to then like you're forcing them or
guilting them to tell their friends
about you and a lot of times that comes
from
helping them beyond just the thing that
you're helping them with like they're
coming to you for a reason cool but
the concept of be their chief goal
officer like what are they actually
trying to accomplish and go help them
accomplish that right so think about i
just came back from vegas and i was
speaking an event and most speakers
pretty much every speaker flies in and
flies out and that's her thing right off
to the next thing my favorite thing is
to hang out in the hallway afterwards so
i speak on stage and then speak so much
in the hallway that zayn has to pull me
aside and say sorry guys last question
he has to go to bed
which is usually nina's job but she
wasn't there so zayn became my my nina
uh
for the for the for the for the trip and
and by the way zandina was very grateful
that you uh stepped in and helped with
that because i i'll get sick because
i'll spend so much time
helping people in the hallway
um but if you think about it like what's
the goal of
what am i being paid to do like to come
and speak
cool but then i'm going to stick around
in the hallway and help everybody
afterwards because
that's helping the client even so much
more
right and then you get hired to come
back and then you get if they're
thinking about who are they going to
recommend to other people to speak
they're going to they're going to often
pick me because of the extra work that
you're putting in so it's not that
you're not doing a good enough job like
well but they got a result cool but did
you help them so much that they feel
like almost guilted into trying other
ways to help you out
and so referrals is the number one way
to grow
a one-on-one client business if you're a
service-based business
the the fastest way to grow it is
through referrals
now that doesn't necessarily scale
right that's not how you build a you
know 10 million dollar company
but it's the fastest way to get going
and get started if we're going to use
content so if you look at build to serve
we tend to always focus on the thought
leadership in the content but
there's three strategies at the back of
the book on how to win right there's the
fast pass of freedom there's
partnerships and then there's thought
leadership and partnerships is basically
what we just talked about it's like
referral strategies
uh for the content
that the best way to do it is to do the
thing that you're doing
live on
inside your content so zan wants to sell
confidence coaching he should be doing
confidence coaching as part of his
content calendar we had somebody in
brand lytics this morning
who was doing
she helps actors
uh
get get into hollywood you know and all
the tips and so one of the video ideas
we came up with was her doing critiques
of people's
audition reels so to get into a film you
have to do an audition reel and send it
in
they never get feedback on whether it
was good or bad they just know if they
got the pot or not so have them send the
audition reel to her
and she'll put a make a video on it
breaking it down critiquing it saying
all the points where
we're we're falling apart like here's
why you didn't get hired i think we
we're going to call like why you didn't
get the role or something and she
basically breaks down and tells you why
you didn't get hired for the job what's
wrong with it
if she wants to sell those services
it's much easier to get clients with
that kind of content than with here are
five ways to win
in hollywood
because the fact that you can speak
doesn't mean you're gonna be a great
coach
so what are you trying to sell and then
show me you doing it
right but the easiest way would be
referrals so i don't know what you're
selling um selena what we're trying to
get clients towards but
go in even for free so drew and jeremy
are two people who i both invested into
and trained the youtube side of things
and they both have mid six figure
businesses now
jeremy was started a little sooner
jeremy went from being
a stock boy at a grocery store making
minimum wage to then now having a mid
six-figure business
and he's like i don't know if i want to
work more than 35 hours a week he's like
oh my gosh this car
uh he's spoiled now jeremy if you watch
replay you are spoiled
um
but how we started was it was
a lot of free calls because he wasn't
very good at the thing yet and so we did
free calls free youtube breakdowns
basically pulling up somebody's channel
and do breakdowns
and that led to then some people on the
free calls would have would call them
back and say hey that was really good
how do i can i hire you
and that becomes the goal it's like you
ultimately want to be hired
but are you doing a good enough job on
the free to the people to say wow i want
i want to hire this person to come back
so
it's outreach
zane had a great point today in
brandlytics where we're pulling up
somebody's channel we didn't know who
they were it's just like using them as
an example it's like could you reach out
to them and tell them to fix their
thumbnails
and offer that as a service like yep
yep
like if that was my business or drew's
business you could reach out and say hey
here's what's here's what's wrong with
your channel here's what i do i'd love
to help you fix it and some people might
just talk to you for half an hour and
take your ideas and run with it cool and
some people will say wow that's awesome
how can i hire you to do that because i
don't want to do that myself
and then those people hire you then you
do a kick-ass job helping them
and then they find more ways to work
with you and refer you off to their
friends
so that's the easiest way
service-based business to get your
company off the ground is referral-based
marketing by doing a kick-ass job for
them
the content
is the scalable way to build the
business
cool so let's uh let's turn into some
questions who's got something how can i
help put your hand up and let's go
through lady lexi what do you got
so when you were talking earlier about
um the whole response videos i was
wondering because you do a lot of those
shorts where your team does on your
gaming channel
and i would really like to respond to
you and get into it so i noticed that on
tick tock you can do some stuff like a
duet or stitch but what do you do when
it's only on on youtube
so can i
post a part of your video like a picture
in picture but what what's the
norm
you need to use something it's like
these is probably zoom
where you screen share and then have you
on as well and just adjust the size of
you
okay
like if i were to go screen share right
now
you i mean we're doing movie makers
right i mean you see my powerpoint
and then you see me still talking and
you can i can adjust the size of me to
be whatever
i make it small so you can see the
slides it's not like giant evan covering
everything up but you can make it that
like ladies half the screen and whatever
you're reacting to is on the other half
that's probably the easiest way
and when it comes to title uh would i
say a response to or would i create a
more catchy title
i would i would leave with a more catchy
title
and then
afterwards if it's not working you can
always look to split test it
okay so for example in in brand linux
this morning we had a guy who was um
he's a copywriter for books for book
marketing
and
he's already ranking at the top for all
of the like book copy
marketing keywords but nobody's
searching for it it's like is it really
small people aren't looking book
marketing copy so he's ranking for all
those but it's not helping him drive his
business forward too much because
nobody's searching for those words
um
so one of the things he does is he does
amazon
sales page copy so when you write a book
you need to have an amazon page and
there's copy on the amazon page and we
went together and looked at the four
hour work week
amazon page and it sucked
it's got like two paragraphs there's
almost nothing on there so
that could be a good video for him
of tearing apart the four-hour workweek
page
and saying why it sucks and how to fix
it
so
the video if you're looking at a title
in that video
there should be something about the
four-hour work week and how much it
sucks as opposed to my response to
the four-hour work workweek sales page
like something that's going to catch
attention so people will want to click
on it
now it's ideally not just tearing it
down but then giving feedback right like
here's here's how to make it better
okay so i i got a little inspired
watching all the the
descriptions on youtube and of course
you got inspired by descriptions on
youtube
yeah that's amazing with how people
actually call themselves i don't think
i've ever heard anybody say that before
ever i got inspired by youtube
descriptions okay this is great you know
that you're like obsessing over youtube
when you leave a question with i got
inspired by youtube descriptions oh my
god
you're basically living inside youtube
right now lady likes you okay i love it
i love it let's go what do you got oh
i'm i'm living in luma fusion right now
it's a whole different ball game anyway
zen calls himself confidence coach
and i've been looking for a while how to
call myself today i was thinking about
um
calling myself
um what was it called again inclusion
influencer because it does have the the
word inclusion in there and i actually
like to see myself as an influencer
that's way easier than code therapist
trainer whatever
okay so you're asking what i think about
inclusion influencer
yes
that's okay i don't know that i would i
don't know that i would lean on an
influencer i think it it's uh
it still has a
22 year old
up and coming vibe to it as opposed to
like if you're actually an expert at it
so like if you're doing inclusion
experts i also saw inclusion creator
passing by
yeah expert or advocate or leader or
like just something with little more if
it were me something with a little more
uh
gravitas to it if you know gravitas uh
with a
little more
stature to it
yeah i'm gonna
influence her i think people will
self-identify as influencers and they
might look for i mean if you're calling
if you're looking at uh inclusion
influencer it's something that nobody's
looking for like nobody's going to
youtube or google anywhere and typing i
need to find an inclusion influencer
right
so
so now it's a branding play like what do
we want to call ourselves is this is not
for
not for somebody searching
so like if somebody's trying to find a
confidence coach then they can find zane
and they you kind of get a sense of what
it is
right like he's a coach he's going to
teach me confidence that's what i assume
it is if i go talk to him when he's
trying to sell me dog food or something
like this there's something wrong here
so but what's it what's a inc inclusion
influencer like you're
you're
it's not immediately understandable so
it's fine it doesn't have to be but if
you're going to then pick something
that's not immediately understandable
then let's pick something that
speaks to speaks to the you know
prestige i guess that you're going after
so if you're going to call yourself an
inclusion leader or advocate
it just comes off i think more
powerfully than influencer
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love